clean up on aisle kamala the vp forced
to do her own damage control after a
brutal report on dysfunction in her
office and allegations that there is a
nasty feud going on between her staff
and joe biden's white house kamala's
team feels like she's being sidelined
and saddled with no wind jobs but the
veep once again just laughing off the
controversy
we're getting things done and we're
doing it together so you don't feel
misused or underused
no i don't i am very very excited about
the work that we have accomplished but i
am also
absolutely absolutely clear-eyed that
there is a lot more to do and we're
going to get it done you know george at
pulls they go up they go down but i
think what is most important is that we
remain consistent
one of those no win jobs harris
reportedly hates is being the face of
joe biden's border disaster kamal is
proving she is way out of her league
when it comes to managing that problem
well it's not going to be overnight we
can't just flip a switch and make it
better
the reality is that we inherit a system
an immigration system that was deeply
broken
and it's requiring us to actually put it
back together in terms of creating a
fair
process that is effective and efficient
and breaking just an hour ago kamala
harris's communications director is out
and we'll be leaving in december all
right greg you've been
stewing over this kamala situation all
day yes i've been stewing and stewing
and stewing the border fiasco is one of
the great untold stories she was given
this plum assignment right and she does
this fact-finding karaoke and then it's
like all done and she pulls the poncho's
pilot washes her hands i don't think
i've ever seen that before where
somebody chooses not to do the job they
give you she's worse than the cable guy
you know the cable guy he'll be four or
five hours late but he'll fix your cable
she didn't she she actually thought all
she had to do was go there meanwhile you
know she's a heartbeat away from the
president and the current heartbeat is
owned currently by joe biden which is
scary she's like the batter the on deck
batter and the pitcher's up at the plate
and you know he's gonna whiff in three
she's that close that's why people are
worried i love that jen sackey blames
all this criticism on
on racism and sexism even though it was
coming from the white house which means
i guess that makes uh joe biden a white
supremacist he did go to a funeral to
the grand cyclops so maybe that's true
but you get the sense that this is the
most inept
uh presidential uh administration in
history yet they've been in politics
forever this isn't like trump who was
the consummate outsider these are
insiders and elites with a combined
experience of probably centuries
and they've been doing this job for
decades and they suck what does that
tell you you need people who aren't in
government to run government so her
answer about the border which was pretty
funny that's trump broke the border and
then she's having a hard time putting it
back together yeah and this is what
makes me really mad about democrats
because this is one of their talking
points and you hear this over and over
again you hear this from jen saki anyone
who's got a difficult problem alejandro
mayorkas we can't wave a magic wand we
can't flip a switch we can't do anything
instantaneous i get it government is
hard work
fixing problems and saving people's
lives takes a lot of effort and elbow
grease and rolling up your sleeves she
doesn't want to do any of those things
again you're not going to fix the
problem now she's not even identifying
the problem in terms of immigration
people are suffering people are
suffering at the border people are
suffering in other countries she doesn't
have a plan for any of it she's not
acknowledging that it's a multi-pronged
issue that she simply doesn't have the
competence to solve but what has
happened in this white house staffers
and the biden administration have
reached critical mass they have decided
that she's the anvil that's pulling the
administration down people voters look
at her and realize she's the plan b and
that's why her poll numbers are lower
because she is actually to a lot of
people who are paying attention now
they say i trust her less than i trust
the president and that is saying
something so that's interesting i hadn't
thought about that and i think about
everything not really the the biden
white house officially the dividend
white house thinks that kamala is a drag
on on joe and they're trying to get rid
of her oh yeah i think that that's the
angle in uh dc now and i i do believe
that i don't know who came first the
west wing or the right wing but i think
they are both now uh in cahoots when it
comes to canceling kamla you know i
don't know if it's about sexism or
racism i i just believe it's because
she's unpopular and she's unpopular
partially because she has refused to be
the energized uh you know sidekick to
make joe biden look good she was
supposed to be the counterpoint he is
and the first of everything and she's
going to go out there and make some
history and i still say she should have
gone and can still go to the to the
the edge of the rio grande yes and say
don't come stop this is not working
maybe we should restart this border wall
uh whatever the you know she blames it
on whoever came before her uh the trump
administration or whoever she'll never
do this is her boogeyman i i think that
she's got to seize the mantle and she's
not she's not doing it uh you know and
an identity is that she is historic she
is the first female asian and
african-american or all the rest of that
uh but you know she's blowing it and and
i think leaving a bad taste for the next
one up and i i i don't appreciate that
are you surprised that there's so much
drama with the first female vice
president no you guys i'm not surprised
at all by any of her failures nor the
drama as a californian as a human that
has been watching her for decades this
is par for the course yeah this is like
you know you have your friend who
assures you oh when we have a baby the
relationship's going to be better or
like as soon as we get married he's
going to change you guys living under
her watch in california she was handed
the d.a nomination in san francisco she
was handed the attorney general position
she's never had to earn she's never had
to cultivate the hearts and minds of
californians and she's never had to earn
her way this is why she dropped out of
the iowa caucus it's because she wasn't
even popular with the democrats she was
pulling it three percent when she
dropped out she raised less money than
mayor pete her percentage was
21
less than his so there's absolutely no
change from that day until now except
for the position she now occupies but
the failures are par for the course she
has always been talk only she has always
changed even the new york times called
her quote an uneven campaigner who
changes her message and tactics to
little effect with a faction staff
what's changed to right now as you said
we just got word that one is leaving in
december nothing has changed everyone
and that should have been an easy
interview for her i mean stephanopoulos
yeah he's a hardcore democrat that's
where you go to clean things up and she
couldn't even do that no she couldn't
with stephanopoulos yes
what is wrong with this country what is
wrong with these people hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else